well I said nowhere in our literature
when I study that we anywhere I
challenged to show me anywhere that
these reservists did what it is that it
is it is countercultural innocent and or
innocent children and it's invaded and
it's implemented in an innocent and
other women - please mrs. Evans and tell
you what will it Harris I'm selfish what
being scared is really ridiculous a lot
works better in the name of Allah been
able to stop irrelevant right owe me
anything
okay okay how about what it takes I
suppose in a sense from the Quran is
irrelevant then as well twisting the sex
on your going boy show me one surah 9:5
I will give me every I don't cut it open
it open hello this is a challenge
tonight don't do it again and you're
forgetting
surah 9 I apply today you cannot every
time I avoid it I like to challenge a
photo tutorial don't wonder if I'm
Italian I'm with mommy
I'm not gonna take that and I want you
to decide you're gonna really pay you in
a minute what are you an idea Michael is
an action for your people and I call
teaspoon of honey can I make my points
or not I apart and I will be blue like
millions of a sec a month ago a month
ago people in any way want to edition
yes exam one thing let me
you can use for your to aya nine one
nine one nine three would be to tell the
unbelievers also for supporting all of
the things Bible I can show your support
you're going to read like that's not
okay I'm in a question of course I love
you Jenny cause I want to avoid Jesus's
love the enemy why make it so happy
don't make war readin in the last month
protection against one day son
so I have a little even I do and I my
channel region I will give me 1000 pound
gosh he says what if I don't know
anywhere in Iran you can't in any hot
region is any person that is going to
innocent men for a night and women
during our children for another baby
what are you doing you don't agree
motivate now you bring them out 74 929
you're going back home you gonna leave
that will be a child a donkey over
anything
he didn't defeat hold on are you
interested in science and always give up
science I just need to tell by the way
why do you can you show me what it is
and then listen to me proud have
yourself surely surah surah 9:29 fight
those who don't believe is that kid man
woman children we're here anywhere else
where we give it is lemon evident in a
minute you just need to put it on the
edge whenever I'll be attending your
skin women's is gonna don't worry I am
under your skin are you okay yeah I'm
enjoying it rotate anyway that shows
aura 820 where that lon it'll be life
you just know everything I'm aiming
right at clinical get lot Muslims going
to innocent men losing confidence a
woman who loses hope you will children a
baby anywhere I would never guys Trinity
for alive anybody can also question I'll
go for a nine one one one what I'm
detail it was why I love
I'm sorry so um be killed by swallow or
8:38 what to normal citrus
that's so much anyway the first incident
here in fact it was I think any day any
case for a nine-day enzyme is not
appreciated that's on a book why I tell
you anyway what does it many ways create
quote a modified into a 929 anywhere by
those who don't believe any of it
anyways enemies of some but don't even
high school if they don't you mustn't
feel it was that going through bruising
that over the ones in the battlefield
let the pig in a room the q1 q2 Alban
evil force or a 9 1 q topology I'm still
watching Suraj III in the Quran is it
easy mister people sort of not one way
to do it make war with your evil so
let's watch the wafer it don't have this
believers as one is very good and evil
intensity provide me a first at gives
you the commandments they love me as a
non-muslim not find or not in other
words look at the Bible take another
five forty five enemies let's not make
his own rules let you know you love the
ones do deny any mortal death no I
clearly asked a simple question I'm
going to demand men who thought that I
was an atheist question and you know the
reason one her offices and you know
where we're going to find these words
I'm about to utter guys listen carefully
he said to me and already once again you
said one month ago three terrorist
attacks up in by Muslim samurai and I'm
I like those that you can act in your
life okay and I love you like my muscles
in Italy okay so if you should love you
in to me let me speak
there was recover attorneys fees look
great they were bad Muslim okay they
were was it bad Muslims get a whoop
agency said it rather to find out from
the flipchart okay now I'm seeing to
this gentleman he often do is say hey
tree trunks he comes you have a nice
clean up can I finish no I reckon if I
refuse to let you be hunted when you're
labeling me be fun is one of these young
people to join a hey
some 103 times I different those that
hang the truth I'm just you are you a
welcome to democracy arrested rapidly
change no is happy to let me finish you
come inside there is tonight fish for
coffee country you said you disability
okay thank you so much I'm here anyway
anyway I want I'm going to die my fries
are a brilliant day of I believe I'm
energized to do some questions up doing
it I as andesaurus life may be that way
I actually want to deal with the
exercise then you are we all want to
hear there now free accessible by
movement we see the bad moves on a white
I'm off to weigh in the front or any
some ignition show that it's holding the
kitties Ross innocent men rock innocent
woman with innocent children it has been
baby I challenge anyone and I have a
thousand pound cash to show me anywhere
in the entire plan and I'm crazy on to
tomorrow okay but one single class about
it with them wherever I went to innocent
as normal it will be immense with the
women children however I will show you
know keep it I know it could be wait a
minute
get away with it let me also questions
answered a question
it is quite to normal videography to
develop our curvature and night target
any Levitt kill and be killed
I know sorta two troopers which I was in
the bar at 9:30 and a possibility there
just another time
because they say Jesus is the Son of God
are you ready 12
come on to 500 929 right those who don't
believe
here's that in a bottle filled everyone
that does not gonna go to the buckle
here company for our 291 to 193 queue
down believers surah 9:5 you know quite
a few that's anyone that's almost an
according to your garage for a 973 quiet
disbelievers surah 9 1 2 3 make walk
with your diesel a Jason for a 328 don't
have disbelievers and I'll give you the
other ones I have that anymore every
birthday is talking about the youth the
night verse 29 years shall deny verse 29
is talking about when the problematic
upon him stance and individual
operations imagine Russia I think what
we didn't need it would you live
they were remembered they sent him here
oh yes he did in there and what the
Romans do they chopped his head off
we did when Russia sent somebody here is
enough when he thinks is not even for
you just understand we cannot interfere
in human tonight I advise the
disbelievers okay yes yes who's he
talking about disbelievers which you
know very well me boy okay permitted in
me oh sorry about the corner
and I don't you must learn for you why
would I want my enemy to tell me about
my own screams under your roof because
you want to question off it horrible
question but you know answer you when
you know just a little aside the house
cherry-picking my license is a technique
for you both Burton I look at this time
it's not realism where I said hey when
your enemies coming to shoot you rock
Palmas I know if your enemy from is to
you you're going to sell the format I
never said that what I said I'm giving
you information of foreign media claimed
that wishing you the I don't want
information I will order your version I
finished with it it's gonna be hey can I
finish
well I'll give it only really speaking
over because we noticed ring and I was
gonna buy it I want to do in this
advertising here you know a is you know
and especially yeah absolutely not even
you fresher you gave any Canadian babies
if we ever could possibly imagine
I said clean anyway in the product
that's it in this versus a burger go to
the non-muslims who their men include a
woman and to their children
I think the baby no I want to give you
another yeah once or or even that you
did is I want to go to a squid shop and
I'm not saying every fish is like this
they Cleveland I was to teach the know
where this porch is personalization is
about are you going to just whatever
support so you're going to skin I do
yell I'm going to the Bible not care to
be removed in that debate which is every
boy chorus and eyes before
and posted a Bible reading a Bible to
come to jesus' login
instead how you treated different River
I need to say this every time one debate
what's going on is what is on TV and
talk me into me though I won't allow
anyone to get paid abusers
I don't make this pretty okay not only
ones unions has a lot so the revealing
of totally photo revolution let me say
why you are enjoy your apartment are you
the customer I'm the kid yeah okay okay
okay okay I'm going to shop thank you no
way my life now is why I was showing
that the hostage okay let's assume that
Senate committee was dais okay might be
he's impressing the Bible yeah we're
busy were dressed in the Quran but I
really nothing no but you want the
question I'm really going to do one
minute comin daddy you said bring me any
verse from the Quran o dhananjaya
children and whatever okay now oh no oh
no I wouldn't know you let me finish
you know bombs and that's why you don't
want to go to coffee no I was not using
it for every day okay and this is about
one now the candles from local high
school education
it's not fair women children they can
feed on whatever odd when I got a favor
and thank you no no come in an
attachment that's how you put abroad to
me that this is your when you come and
attack to which it doesn't happen with
kindness and justice antonin Georgie
beautiful tomatoes and then tell me that
my Saturday morning Laurie so my dream
is just no stairs no somebody no hope
that I won't bring down love between you
and those delusions in there
you're lying again and you say the
Christian where does it say that maybe
the Christian talking about emotion
it is a sin if you can say to any Muslim
have a push is a non Muslims I'm going
with office eliminating positions that
the guards grow over here today know
what means you know I'm actually need to
be because I'm going to see Cole doesn't
need me for yourself from here right
away
by the way I'm a Christian I don't know
this man let me don't know nothing there
but here like hell
okay we're going to have warmer right
and it comes with equal ninety-nine
point nine nine zero do it so what would
be this besides come soon
human English
Oh
[Music]